la mitad de contagios y decesos diarios
por kobe 19 a nivel mundial se registran
en europa la situación epidemiológica es
muy preocupante según la califica la o
ms according to one driver proyección de
acuerdo con una proyección fiable si nos
mantenemos en esa trayectoria podríamos
ver otro medio millón de muertes por
commit 19 en europa y asia central para
el primero de febrero del próximo año
entre los focos de alta incidencia se
encuentran rusia croacia eslovenia
ucrania o alemania las autoridades
alemanas ya hablan de la cuarta ola de
la que llaman la pandemia de los no
vacunados y plantean aplicar
restricciones para los no inmunizados en
el estado de baviera el personal médico
se declara agotado frente a este nuevo
pico epidemiológico
la variante delta es claramente más
contagiosa además entramos en la
estación fría del año también las
escuelas están abiertas y los niños no
están vacunados es un fenómeno donde
intervienen muchos factores pero no
sería así si el índice de vacunación de
la población fuera más elevado está
claro mientras que las autoridades de
kiev
720 de funciones por kobe 19 el
miércoles sólo por detrás de las cifras
reportadas por washington y moscú
la gente no entiende lo que está
sucediendo aquí en el hospital hay
muchos pacientes la mayoría en estado
grave y un alto porcentaje no está
vacunado la media de vacunación en el
continente europeo es del 55 por ciento
sin embargo las cifras son dispares en
cada país por ejemplo en ucrania la tasa
de población completamente vacunada es
del 17% en rusia del 33 en alemania del
66 y en españa' del 80% allí las
autoridades sanitarias se felicitan de
estar en una mucho mejor situación que
en los territorios de su entorno